it may seem like we're all standing on
solid earth right now but we're not the
rocks and the dirt underneath us are
criss crossed by tiny little fractures
and empty spaces and these empty spaces
are filled with astronomical quantities
of microbes such as these ones the
deepest that we found microbes so far
into the earth is five kilometers down
so like if you pointed yourself at the
ground and like took off running like
into the ground
you could run an entire 5k race and
microbes would line your whole path you
may not have ever thought about these
microbes that are deep inside Earth's
crust but you've probably thought about
the microbes living in our guts so if
you add up the gut microbiomes of all
the people and all the animals on the
planet collectively this weighs about a
hundred thousand tons this is a huge
biome that we carry in our bellies every
single day we should all be proud but it
pales in comparison to the number of
microbes that are covering the entire
surface of the earth like in our soils
our rivers and our oceans collectively
these weigh about two billion tons but
it turns out that the majority of
microbes on earth aren't even in oceans
or our guts or sewage treatment plants
most of them are actually inside the
Earth's crust so collectively these
weigh 40 billion tons this is one of the
biggest biomes on the planet and we
didn't even know it existed until a few
decades ago so the possibilities for
what life is like down there or what it
might do for humans are limitless this
is a map showing a red dot for every
place where we've gotten pretty good
deep subsurface samples with like modern
microbiological methods and you may be
impressed that we're getting a pretty
good global coverage but actually if you
remember that these are the only places
that we have samples from it looks a
little worse like if we were all in an
alien spaceship trying to reconstruct a
map the globe from only these samples
we'd never be able to do it
um so people sometimes say to me yeah
there's a lot of microbes in the
subsurface but aren't they just kind of
dormant this is a good point relative to
a ficus plant or the measles or my kids
guinea pigs these microbes probably
aren't doing much of anything at all we
know that they have to be slow because
there's so many of them if they all
started dividing at the rate of e.coli
then they would double the entire weight
of the earth rocks included over a
single night in fact many of them
probably haven't even undergone a single
cell division since the time of ancient
Egypt which is just crazy like how do
you wrap your head around things that
are so long-lived but I thought of an
analogy that I really love but it's
weird and it's complicated so I hope
that you can all sort of go there with
me all right let's try it it's like
trying to figure out the life cycle of a
tree if you only live for a day so like
if human lifespan was only a day and we
lived in winter then you would go your
entire life without ever seeing a tree
with a leaf on it and there would be so
many human generations that would pass
by within a single winter that you may
not even have access to a history book
that says anything other than the fact
that trees are always lifeless sticks
they don't do anything well of course
this is ridiculous we know that trees
are just waiting for summer so they can
reactivate but if the human lifespan
were significantly shorter than that of
trees we might be completely oblivious
to this totally mundane fact so when we
say that these deep subsurface microbes
are just dormant are we like people who
died after a day trying to figure out
how trees work what if these deep
subsurface organisms are just waiting
for their version of summer but we our
lives are too short for us to see it if
you take ecoli and seal it up in a test
tube with no food or nutrients and you
leave it there for months to years most
of the cells die off of course because
they're starving but a few of the cells
survive if you take these old surviving
cells and compete them also under
starvation conditions against a new
fast-growing culture of e.coli
the grizzled old tough guys beat out the
squeaky-clean
upstarts every single time so this is
evidence there's actually an
evolutionary payoff to being
extraordinarily slow so it's possible
that maybe we should be maybe we should
not equate being slow with being
unimportant
maybe these out-of-sight out-of-mind
microbes could actually be helpful to
humanity okay so as far as we know there
are two ways to do subsurface living the
first is to wait for food to trickle
down from the surface world like trying
to eat the leftovers of a picnic that
happened a thousand years ago which is a
crazy way to live but shockingly seems
to work out for a lot of microbes in
earth the other possibility is for a
microbe to just say Nath I don't need
the surface world
I'm good down here for microbes that go
this route they have to get everything
that they need in order to survive from
inside the earth some things are
actually easier for them to get they're
more abundant inside the Earth's like
water or nutrients like nitrogen and
iron and phosphorus or places to live
these are things that we literally kill
each other to get ahold of up at the
surface world but in the subsurface the
problem is finding enough energy up at
the surface plants can chemically knit
together carbon dioxide molecules into
yummy sugars as fast as the sun's
photons hit their leaves but in the
subsurface of course there's no sunlight
so this ecosystem has to solve the
problem of who is gonna make the food
for everybody else the subsurface needs
something that's like a plant but it
breeds rocks
luckily such a thing exists and it's
called a chemo with the autotrophs which
is a microbe that uses chemicals chemo
from rocks litho to make food
autotrophs and they can do this with a
ton of different elements they can do
this with sulfur iron manganese nitrogen
carbon some of them can use pure
electrons straight-up like if you cut
the end off of an electrical cord they
could breathe it like a snorkel
these chemo little auto trains take the
energy that they get from these
processes and use it to make food like
plants do but we know that plants do
more than just make food they also make
a waste product oxygen which we are 100%
dependent upon but the waste product
these chemo let the autotrophs make is
often in the form of minerals like rust
or pyrite like fool's gold or carbonates
like limestone so what we have are
microbes that are really really slow
like rocks that get their energy from
rocks but make us their waste product
other rocks so am I talking about
biology or am I talking about geology
this stuff really blurs the lines so if
I'm gonna do this thing and I'm gonna be
a biologist who studies microbes that
kind of act like rocks then I should
probably start studying geology and
what's the coolest part of geology
volcanoes this is looking inside the
crater of poas volcano in Costa Rica
many volcanoes on earth arise because an
oceanic tectonic plate crashes into a
continental plate is this oceanic plate
subducts or gets moved underneath this
continental plate things like water and
carbon dioxide and other materials get
squeezed out of it like wringing a wet
washcloth so in this way subduction
zones are like portals into the deep
earth where materials are exchanged
between the surface and the subsurface
world so I was recently invited by some
of my colleagues in Costa Rica to come
and work with them on some of the
volcanoes and of course I said yes
because I mean Costa Rica is beautiful
but also because it sits on top of one
of these subduction zones we wanted to
ask the very specific question why is it
that the carbon dioxide that comes out
of this deeply buried oceanic tectonic
plate is only coming out at the
volcanoes why don't we see it
distributed throughout the entire
subduction zone do the microbes have
something to do with that
so this is a picture of me inside po s
volcano
along with my colleague did not achieve
an le that lake
that we're standing next to is made of
pure battery acid I know this because we
were measuring the pH when this picture
was taken and at some point while we're
working inside the crater I turned to my
my colleague my Costa Rican colleague
Carlos Ramirez and I said all right if
this thing starts erupting right now
what's our exit strategy when he said oh
yeah great question it's totally easy
just turn around and enjoy the view
because it will be your last and it may
sound like he was being overly dramatic
but 54 days after I was standing next to
that Lake this happened freaking
terrifying right this was the biggest
eruption that this volcano had had in 60
some-odd years and not long after this
video ends the camera that was taking
the video is obliterated and the entire
lake that we had been sampling vaporizes
completely but I also want to be clear
that we're pretty sure this is not gonna
happen on the day that we were actually
in the volcano because Costa Rica
monitors its volcano is very carefully
through the off seek Ori Institute and
we had scientists from that Institute
with us on that day but the fact that it
erupted illustrates perfectly that if
you want to look for where carbon
dioxide gas is coming out of this
oceanic plate then you should look no
further than the volcanoes themselves
but if you go to Costa Rica you may
notice that in addition to these
volcanoes are tons of cosy little Hot
Springs all over the place some of the
water in these Hot Springs is actually
bubbling up from this deeply buried
oceanic plate and our hypothesis was
that there should be carbon dioxide
bubbling up with it but something deep
underground was filtering it out so we
spent two weeks driving all around Costa
Rica sampling every hot spring we could
find it was awful let me tell you and
then we spent the next two years
measuring and analyzing data and if
you're not a scientist I'll just let you
know that the big discoveries don't
really happen when you're in a beautiful
hot spring or on a public stage they
happen when you're hunched over a messy
computer or you're troubleshooting a
difficult instrument
or your skyping your colleagues because
you are completely confused about your
data scientific discoveries kind of like
deep subsurface microbes can be very
very slow but in our case this really
paid off this one time we discovered
that literally tons of carbon dioxide
were coming out of this deeply buried
oceanic plate and the thing that was
keeping them underground and keeping it
from being released out into the
atmosphere was that deep underground
underneath all the adorable sloths and
toucans of Costa Rica were kheema with
autotrophs these microbes and the
chemical processes that were happening
around them were converting this carbon
dioxide into carbonate mineral and
locking it up underground which makes
you wonder if these subsurface processes
are so good it's sucking up all the
carbon dioxide coming from below them
could they also help us with a little
carbon problem we've got going on up at
the surface humans are releasing enough
carbon dioxide into our atmosphere that
we are decreasing the ability of our
planet to support life as we know it
scientists and engineers and
entrepreneurs are working on methods to
pull carbon dioxide out of these point
sources so that they're not released
into the atmosphere and they need to put
it somewhere so for this reason we need
to keep studying places where this
carbon might be stored possibly in the
subsurface to know what's gonna happen
to it when it goes there well these deep
subsurface microbes be a problem because
they're too slow to actually keep
anything down there or will they be
helpful because they'll help convert all
this stuff to solid carbonate minerals
if we can make such a big breakthrough
just from one study that we did in Costa
Rica then imagine what else is waiting
to be discovered down there this new
field of geo biochemistry or deep
subsurface biology or whatever you want
to call it is gonna have huge
implications not just for mitigating
climate change but possibly for
understanding how life and Earth have
co-evolved or finding new products that
are useful for industrial or medical
applications maybe even predicting
earthquakes or finding life outside our
planet it could even help us understand
the origin of life itself
fortunately I don't have to do this by
myself
there I have amazing colleagues all over
the world who are cracking into the
mysteries of this deep subsurface world
and it may seem like life buried deep
within the Earth's crust is so far away
from our daily experiences that it's
kind of irrelevant but the truth is that
this weird slow life may actually have
the answers to some of the greatest
mysteries of life on earth thank you
[Applause]